alors vous allez me dire c'est un sujet
vu revu mais non en fait parce qu'on va
aborder les choses sous un autre angle
on va essayer de voir les choses un
petit peu différemment justement là j'ai
moi même eu un accès de créativité
récemment puisque j'ai refait le
générique de la chaîne générique 2020
d'ailleurs vous me direz ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires
juste après l'intro
[Musique]
et c'est lui les gens derrière l'écran
c'est françois pour la chaîne explique
mme encore je suis ravie comme toujours
de vous retrouver une nouvelle fois sur
cette chaîne d'ailleurs si vous vous
intéressez à la vidéo en général aux
caméras au matériel tout ça vous êtes
tombé sur la bonne chaîne donc vous
pouvez envisager de cliquer sur le petit
bouton s'abonner qui se situe juste en
dessous là juste en dessous de la vidéo
pour expliquer la cloche tout ça parce
que y aura sûrement des choses qui vont
vous intéressez sur cette chaîne alors
la créativité c'est un sujet très vaste
et très complexe eh ben on en entend
beaucoup parler surtout en ce moment et
c'est très bien d'ailleurs c'est très
bien d'exercer sa créativité mais j'ai
eu envie de l'aborder sous un angle un
petit peu différente de ce qu'on peut
voir d'habitude avec des conseils et des
secrets qui ne sont pas forcément abordé
dans les vidéos traditionnelles qu'on
peut trouver sur youtube qui sont ceci
étant dit souvent très bien fait aussi
on ne s'est pas un jugement de valeur
c'est juste une autre façon de voir les
choses parce que je m'interroge un petit
peu sur les conseils créatif dit
classique
est ce que si on vous donne une marche à
suivre et que vous l'appliquez vous
devenez créative ça je vous laisse en
débattre dans les commentaires et de me
dire si vraiment c'est de la créativité
ou pas j'ai pas forcément la réponse à
cette question mais ça m'intéresse de
savoir votre opinion mais alors du coup
pour aborder le sujet de la créativité
je me suis dit que la meilleure chose à
faire avant tout démarrage c'était de
définir exactement ce qu était la
créativité et je suis donc allé ouvrir
mon dictionnaire
enfin non je suis allé sur internet sur
le larousse en ligne ce jeune équipe qui
a encore un dictionnaire qui avez vous
un dictionnaire chez vous un
dictionnaire papier donc je n'ai pas de
dictionnaire mais j'ai internet pour
répondre à cette question c'est quoi
être créatif c'est quoi la créativité la
créativité selon donc le dictionnaire
larousse c'est la capacité faculté
d'invention d'imagination de création le
pouvoir créateur ouais pas forcément un
truc qui nous avance beaucoup on va
aller voir les finitions de créer à
leurs essais réalisés ou concevoir
quelque chose tout simplement et ça va
être tout ça notre base de départ pour
ses conseils l'a déjà de bien comprendre
ce que c'est donc c'est parti pour ces
cinq conseils ces cinq secrets de
créativité qui n'engage que moi encore
une fois un jeu le précise et on
commence tout de suite par le numéro un
être créatif ce n'est pas forcément
rechercher à tout prix
l'originalité ah ça c'est un gros souci
un confondre la créativité et
l'originalité être créatif on l'a vu
dans l'année
finition c'est tout simplement créer
quelque chose donc c'est très important
de se détacher un petit peu de cette
notion d'originalité on avait déjà parlé
dans une autre vidéo qui s'affiche
quelque part pas ici chercher
l'originalité c'est parfois un énorme
frein à la créativité puisque si on
cherche quelque chose qui n'a jamais été
fait qui est purement original ben on va
galérer une galères et méchamment
puisque ben il ya quand même beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses pour ne pas
dire tous qui a déjà été fait mais pas
par vous donc quand on part filmait
quelque chose quand on veut créer
l'image est bonne
déjà il faut essayer de s'affranchir de
cette idée d'originalité ne pas partir
dans l'optique de se dire je vais faire
un truc qui n'a jamais été fait parce
que souvent c'est quelque chose qui est
très bloquant au niveau des idées
le fait de reprendre quelque chose qui a
été fait de filmer quelque chose que
vous avez déjà filmé ça n'est pas du
tout problématique dans la mesure où
vous créez ça entraîne une dynamique et
puis aussi fait que vous ne savez pas ce
qui peut se passer pendant un tournage
un tournage qui peut avoir l'air
totalement bateau quelque chose que vous
avez fait cinquante mille fois bas il
suffit que il y ait un alignement de
planètes bas ce tournage se transforme
en quelque chose de très créatif voire
même de quelque chose d'original mais il
suffira par exemple qu' il ya une
lumière ce jour là très particulière qui
rendent votre tournage complètement ou
qu'ils aient des émotions qui se dégage
de ce que vous allez film et qui vont
être unique ce jour là parce que ça a
été ce jour-là vous l'aviez pas prévu et
au final on va avoir quelque chose de
très créatif et de très joli et ça va
stimuler aussi éventuellement votre
créativité votre imagination
voyons maintenant le deuxième conseil
c'est plutôt une maxime en fait qu'un
conseil mais vous allez voir c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut suivre et qu'il
faut absolument à mon avis suivre c'est
que les choses changent plus
difficilement que le regard qu'on peut
porter sur elle vous vous dites qu
est-ce qui viennent dit il il a pris des
produits bizarre et il est fou non non
vous allez voir je vous expliquais pas
de souci en fait c'est très simple
souvent on se dit que on a fait un peu
le tour des choses qu'on a filmé des
choses qu'on sait filmer des endroits où
on a pu aller filmer et ça nous bloque
on dit il faudrait que j'aille dans un
endroit extraordinaire
il faudrait que j'aie quelque chose
d'extraordinaire à filmer que j'ai
jamais vu et ça c'est pas du tout une
raison suffisante et au contraire ça
peut être encore une fois un gros frein
à votre créativité
c'est sûr qu'au bout d'un moment dans
notre environnement habituel
eh ben on a l'impression de tourner un
petit peu en rond c'est pour ça que
c'est très important de changer et
d'essayer de changer son regard sur les
choses quelque chose que vous avez déjà
film est dix fois est ce que vous l'avez
film est toujours au même moment de la
journée où est ce qu'il n'ya pas par
exemple un moment où vous n'avez jamais
filmé cet endroit ça peut être de nuit
ça peut être le matin ça peut être le
soir ça peut être en plein après midi
bref le moment de la journée peut être
très intéressant et il ya aussi tout
simplement l'angle le regard est ce que
vous avez filmé certaines choses avec
toutes les focales possible depuis tous
les points possibles depuis tous les
angles possibles c'est certainement pas
le cas parce que sinon ça prendrait un
temps monstrueux ou alors vraiment vous
avez beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup shooté mais
clairement c'est une piste à explorer à
les filmer des choses que vous avez déjà
filmé mais placez-vous tout simplement à
d'autres endroits utilisés d'autres
focale vous avez fait du large
l'habitude fait du sert et vous étiez en
contrebas mettez-vous en hauteur bref
tout ça ça peut vraiment aider à la
créativité plus que des petits trucs
voilà de mettre des gouttes d'eau sur
son objectif et tout ça c'est très beau
lire dans le long terme c'est pas
forcément le truc le plus utile de la
terre ça occupe
ça occupe créativement parlant et c'est
sympa mais ça ou clé le troisième point
c'est surtout de prendre la créativité
comme elle vient parce qu'on connaît
tous ces périodes où on a l'impression
de n'avoir aucune idée où qu'elles sont
toutes nul
eh ben vous dites vous que c'est
complètement normal votre cerveau il a
besoin a certainement fonctionner
correctement de s'ennuyer et
et d'être au repos donc y'a pas de souci
avec ça l'ennuie et le manque de
créativité bizarrement c'est des choses
qui peuvent stimuler la créativité
puisqu'il va y avoir d'autres périodes
d'autres moments où là pour le coup vous
allez avoir plein d'idées et c'est là
qu'il faut pas se laisser avoir c'est là
qu'il faut pas remettre au lendemain le
fait de pouvoir aller tourner si vous
avez une idée de vous dire bon bah oui
chez steed et laborde girel fait notre
foi non si vous êtes créatif si vous
avez l'idée si vous êtes dans une
période
justement de créativité il faut
l'exploiter jusqu'au bout il faut
prendre le plus de temps possible tant
que votre cerveau disponible tant que
vous avez les idées est allé les
exploiter à fond ya des hauts et des bas
et c'est complètement normal mais
justement quand on est sur des périodes
de haute créativité de deux pleins
d'idées ben c'est pas le moment en fait
de procrastiner c'est le moment d'aller
bosser et d'aller mettre toute cette
créativité à profit ne surtout pas
reporter en fait quand vous avez cette
possibilité le quatrième conseil c'est
tout simplement de garder des traces de
vos idées parce que justement quand vous
êtes en période créative vous n'êtes pas
forcément disponibles vous avez pas
forcément ce qu'il faut sous la main
pour l'être moi personnellement je sais
que je remplis mon application de prise
de note sur mon téléphone de dizaines et
de dizaines d'idées qui parfois
n'aboutit strictement à rien et qui
parfois donne des vidéos et là
typiquement la vidéo qui est en train de
tourner c'est une idée que j'avais noté
dans une note
il ay ay père longtemps il ya un choix
de trois mois et que j'avais pas
forcément le temps de tourner j'avais
pas forcément développé non plus mais
j'avais juste eu cette idée vise qu'un
niveau créativité ça serait bien de voir
les choses différemment prenez des notes
vraiment écrivait tous des notes vocales
éventuellement aussi si vous n'avez pas
la possibilité si vous n'avez pas le
temps d'écrire et tout mais surtout
écrivait tout garder tout ça et de temps
en temps
faites un petit tour quand vous êtes en
période creuse justement que vous n'avez
pas d'idées ou de pas créatif fait un
petit tour de toutes les notes que vous
avez prises ça va sûrement raviver des
choses que vous avez éventuellement
oublié et ça va vous permettre peut-être
de vous donner un nouvel élan de
créativité
enfin le cinquième et dernier conseil et
qui est le plus
important de tous c'est qu'il faut
accepter de ne pas être créatif en
permanence même vos créateurs préférés
même tous les gens dont vous admirez les
vidéos il ya des moments ils sont pas
créatif ya des moments ils ont pas
d'idées ils sont exactement comme vous
ne pas être créatif tout le temps c'est
quelque chose de normal il n'y a pas à
culpabiliser il n'y a pas à se sentir
moins bon tout ça par rapport à ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut accepter ce que
je disais dans le point numéro 3 il ya
des hauts et des bas il faut accepter
les bas il faut accepter les eaux il y
aurait pas l'un sans l'autre en fait
donc les périodes de non créativité et
ben c'est normal c'est normal il faut
pas non plus et y ait de forces est trop
la créativité parce qu'au final on
risque de ne pas être satisfait de ce
qu'on a fait on va éventuellement même
centre dégoûté donc accepté sap en train
de dire que c'est une raison pour jamais
se triturer un peu le cerveau essayer de
trouver des idées mais juste ce que je
dis c'est qu'il faut pas forcer la
créativité sinon c'est plus vraiment de
la créativité si elle est fort c'est là
aussi c'est un débat et voilà les gens
c'est tout pour moi aujourd'hui j'espère
que cette vidéo vous aura plu qu'elle
vous aura aidé dans votre réflexion si
c'est le cas mettez nous le traditionnel
coup de gloucester sur le pouce en l'air
qui se situe juste en dessous de cette
vidéo si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné
c'est le moment de cliquer sur le petit
bouton d'activer la cloche tout ça de
laïcs et de commenter de partager bref
de faire en sorte qu'on arrive très vite
à ces cinquante mille abonnés passent on
n'est vraiment pas loin un truc de fou
et puis moi les amis je vous dis comme
d'habitude rester curieux chez vous et
créatifs et à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo
alors j'ai commencé à écrire une
nouvelle formation
ça va être un énorme morceau genre yahoo
au moins quatre ou cinq heures de
formation de danse se sera pas avant le
mois de septembre je pense que ce sera
fini parce qu'il ya plein de choses
mettre dedans mais mais vous allez
halluciner de tout ce qui va y avoir
dedans ça va être un truc de malade
deux malades et en plus c'est un truc
qui on voit pas souvent en tout cas moi
j'ai jamais eu donc suspecte